vamos a hacer un repaso de las noticias
económicas en el mundo con el periodista
luís méndez de zúrich un saludo
nuevamente para ustedes luis y vamos a
recordar que el presidente de eeuu joe
biden anunció el fortalecimiento de la
relación con la asociación de naciones
del sudeste asiático un cambio grande
respecto a la administración anterior
por supuesto que sí y por ello destinará
recursos por el orden de los 100
millones de dólares este anuncio se
presenta en medio de la cumbre virtual
que lleva adelante el organismo y
representa la vuelta de eeuu a un evento
que había estado ausente desde el año
2017 bajo el mando de donald trump para
bailén el acercamiento con la asean
significa un compromiso para fortalecer
la presencia de eeuu en el pacífico
frente al crecimiento de china
escuchemos
tenemos la intención de lanzar un nuevo
programa de iniciativas para mejorar
nuestra cooperación con una variedad de
temas por un total de más de 100
millones de dólares nuestra conclusión
final es que la asean es esencial quiero
decir esto es esencial para la
arquitectura regional del indo pacífico
eeuu está comprometido con la
centralidad de la asean es un eje para
mantener la resiliencia la prosperidad y
la seguridad de nuestra región
compartida
el siguiente tema ha sido protagonista
en nuestros noticieros en ecuador hay
protestas en contra de las reformas
económicas de la zona así es ángela y
estas medidas que desde que fueron
anunciadas en septiembre pasado han
causado malestar en una parte de la
población la jornada de protestas se
desarrolla días después que el
presidente anunció un congelamiento en
el precio de la gasolina extra y el
diesel que fue denunciado por algunos
sectores como un aumento disfrazado el
presidente no se ha pronunciado al
respecto del sistema de bandas
establecido en el gobierno de lenin
moreno en 2020 donde el precio de los
combustibles fluctúa con el precio del
barril de petróleo y ante su aumento
este año ha disparado el precio tanto de
la gasolina como de él dice pero la
propuesta de reforma se establece bajo
una ley que llamó creación de
oportunidades y está dividida en tres
áreas en cuanto a la materia tributaria
promete deducciones en el impuesto sobre
la renta para personas que han a más de
24.000 dólares anuales en materia
laboral establece la creación de un
régimen alternativo
oportunidades al tiempo que para atraer
la inversión entre otras cosas propone
el establecimiento de zonas francas con
incentivos tributarios en ciertas áreas
en septiembre plazo sustento estas
medidas en el estado de la economía
ecuatoriana que presenta una deuda
pública de 63 mil millones de dólares y
un déficit fiscal de 7 mil millones de
dólares y mientras tanto en chile avanza
la discusión para el cuarto retiro del
10% del fondo de pensiones y de acuerdo
con el diario 'el mercurio' de ese país
la iniciativa ya fue aprobada por la co
la comisión de constitución que estudia
la medida y ahora pasará a sala para un
debate general pero esta propuesta está
generando una mayor división entre el
oficialismo y la oposición que sostiene
que busca ayudar a la economía a los
oficialistas y entre ellos algunos
expertos han estado en contra por los
daños que le causaría a la economía y
así lo hizo saber el presidente
sebastián piñera cuando manifestó que el
retiro del 10% va a producir un efecto
muy destructivo y muy perjudicial en las
pensiones futuras de nuestros adultos
mayores y también en nuestra economía y
bueno siguen los informes 3 es de las
empresas que hay para destacar en esto
se van a conocer las ganancias o
pérdidas respecto al periodo de julio a
septiembre entre ellos la empresa
alphabet matriz de cv que reportó
ingresos en el período de 65 mil 120
millones de dólares y con ellos superó
las estimaciones que lo ubicaban en 63
mil 340 millones de dólares otra empresa
que también reportó ganancia fue
microsoft la empresa de bill gates
generó ingresos por el orden de 45 mil
300 millones de dólares quien no pudo
alcanzar las estimaciones y estuvo por
debajo fue la empresa twitter que
registró ingresos de 1.284 millones de
dólares mil millones menos que las
proyecciones dadas a conocer bueno luis
y por favor hable nos acerca de la
disputa de comercial hay que involucrar
a china y australia una disputa que ya
la organización internacional mundial
del comercio está investigando los
derechos de china para imponer aranceles
al vino australiano así lo informó a
través de un comunicado emitido este
martes china impuso aranceles a albín
australiano en noviembre de 2020 que no
le permiten ser competitivos en el
mercado
forma parte del proceso de
debilitamiento comercial que se produce
entre ambos países desde el año 2018 y
es momento de los indicadores de la
jornada cerraron con números positivos
en el mercado de wall street- todos
estos resultados trimestrales en europa
hubo cierres positivos ya arrancó el
mercado japonés con una leve caída
mientras que en américa latina hubo
cierres mixtos durante la jornada para
despedirnos de la cifra rápidamente te
digo que fueron 90 euros los que
entregará el gobierno español para
ayudar en la calefacción de los más
necesitados siguen en france 24
[Música]